foreign
[Music]
look this guy's trying to walk away so
let's start with that no matter what
happens from this point on now it is her
fault no matter even how it started
he's walking away right
you just let's do his doordash delivery
God damn it yep also Frozen is that you
you're riding the bike on the street
ma'am because it's illegal to ride it on
the sidewalk
I'm so flying [ __ ]
what's your problem
who are you
Karen
why are you even entertaining her
you know
he's nicer by the way
at this point
is she [ __ ] drunk or something
you don't [ __ ] write your oh so now
now we have a war of the side to say
that you're encouraging this
step your mouth shut the [ __ ] up
shut the [ __ ] up and eat your food
by the way I am on the side of the food
delivery guy in the side of the guy
filming right now
because I'm [ __ ] sorry but dude all
these F all these Fockers that are
sitting there relied on these same food
delivery guys to go while they were
hiding in their homes with their little
mask on because it's New York right
probably is what it looks like they're
hiding with their little mask on their
little house because they're so scared
and then but they didn't give a [ __ ]
that this guy had the rightest [ __ ]
bicycle 53 blocks to deliver their
Chinese food so [ __ ] you [ __ ] you and
[ __ ] you okay how about that you [ __ ]
all of you this entire city is full of
[ __ ] and then the people that [ __ ]
try to help you in this [ __ ] City you
[ __ ] [ __ ] on them because they're
riding their bike on the street bro
being an Uber Eats or doordash I always
tip them well that job [ __ ] sucks but
I use it so what am I gonna do make fun
of them and make their life harder what
kind of piece of [ __ ] are you anyway
foreign
[Music]
oh that hurt me oh that hurt me oh my
God is that his wife oh my God oh my God
oh my God oh my God
no wonder
though bro I don't give a [ __ ] if the
guy was in the right or the wrong
control your woman dude bust where's
Buster Rhymes when you need him
where is bust the Rhymes when you need
him yo when we [ __ ] your girl tell her
to get her hands off of me [ __ ]
now they're in the most base breakfast
of all time right now [ __ ] love Busta
Rhymes man
crazy
they don't want to control her it's a
problem
[Music]
I mean he said it's good that his shoes
he called her psycho
no I mean she is
I know that's the trigger word for these
[ __ ] people these people you know
what's funny about these people people
like her she probably has a coexist
bumper sticker and believes that you
know we need to take care of the
minority this guy's obviously not white
right take care of minorities I
guarantee you bro she has the vibe so
there's a guy sitting down his little
restaurant they're always like this
they're always [ __ ] like this bro I
have never seen somebody riding their
bicycle on a sidewalk and have ever
cared in my entire [ __ ] life it's a
bicycle if you can't walk around a
bicycle you're a [ __ ] [ __ ] the
person is the same with on a bike or not
you know what I mean
we used to do it for many many years
guys that's what I did as a as a matter
of fact I remember being told when I was
a kid
by my parents they preferred me to ride
on the sidewalk and to write on this
right am I wrong like they preferred you
to ride on the sidewalk because it was
safer you know the side far the sidewalk
is for regular walking not fancy walking
that's crazy
all of a sudden look there's another guy
that just went buying a bike in the same
[ __ ] path
by the way why is this guy even putting
up with it I wouldn't put up with it
yeah yeah same yeah you can't ask a
question
but let's change this guy from a you
know Brown what brown brown skinny guy
so let's pretend the delivery person was
a I don't know New York Rican woman how
do you think this would have ended do
you think it would have ended the same
way
uh that'll be it would be a fist fight
maybe some hair grabbing maybe a knife
could be involved that woman would be in
this with the trash can yeah yeah that's
where we're going head first
head first into the [ __ ] trash can
for being such a [ __ ] [ __ ] because
earlier black folks use trash cans as a
weapon
Puerto Ricans right
wait is another Karen coming to help
no there's two of them what do you what
do you
what do you call a Flocka a flock of
[ __ ] Karen's what's a flock of
Karen's called you know because like a
flock of crows right murder I want to
say a gaggle but I've used that too many
times a [ __ ] of Karen's there you go
there it is a [ __ ] of Karen's they're
[ __ ] terrible these people leave this
guy alone bro this guy [ __ ] suck
again you know a lot of times I get
criticized for ripping on Puerto Ricans
and honestly we do need them in our
ecosystem because they would have take
care of this really quick this would not
have been an issue it was a Puerto Rican
woman on that bicycle or even a Puerto
Rican man this would not have been
problem okay
um
Puerto Ricans are good for two things
stopping women like this and moving in
when the blacks move out
she's obviously psycho
quote me
I can't argue yeah
can you leave this guy alone
nobody wearing Birkenstocks in a Stone
Cold Steve Austin jean shorts should be
[ __ ] acting this tough right
okay at this point Didn't we learn that
this is assault now
she is now assaulting him
because she is not letting him leave
peacefully
the cops he's looking for orders
[Music]
that I do kind of want to read the
comments for this one I'm wondering
where people are going to lie on this
one it's Reddit so it could be anywhere
can you call 9-1-1
why would he call 9-1-1 bro just leave
all right hold on extensive 100 and chat
a flock of carrots is called a book club
a book club
a book club book club that's not bad I
like it completely opposite direction
just as good just as good that's good
they both work
you know what you call a flock of
lesbians
um a flannel oh a flannel of lesbians
I like when they all link up in a circle
sorry you just call it a software you
know you know you know what you call a
flock of gay guys
[Laughter]
I don't know how I can maggot maggots
there you go come on bro that was an
easy one that was an easy one
Bob Saget's
oh no husband
has
activated hold on man bun
oh boy okay but you can't knock people
for that are
no I [ __ ] will man bun
skips legs days built like a lesbian
[ __ ] it he looks like a lesbian he let
it go on yeah [ __ ] Mr gygax you're
not making anything better here please
leave
he looks like a character Eric would be
playing in a Tim and Eric sketch you
know whenever Tim Heidecker allows Eric
to be funny yeah whenever he whenever he
doesn't get mad that Eric may be
upstaging him in a skit
funnier of the two and I'll [ __ ] die
on that goddamn Hill Tim gets a lot of
[ __ ] Eric was [ __ ] hilarious
actually of the two like I just never
like [ __ ] Tim But Eric was kind of
funny occasionally yeah
okay now you're ganging up on him bro
start swinging
swing
swing
as she's arguing I didn't touch you I
pushed your bike
okay
my mistake then madam
this works it's not how any of this
works
ma'am have you ever called the cops
what do you think the response time is
I'm sorry did she go if you really
called the cops they'd be here by now
ma'am
do you know how police work this video
is we're only four minutes in even if
they were the best cops in the [ __ ]
planet
it would take longer than four minutes
right
especially if they're you know solving a
bodega murder
because you're mad that this guy's
delivering McDonald's to somebody on his
[ __ ] bicycle
come on now he's finally moving he's
finally doing it
still think women should vote
I don't think they should be allowed out
of the [ __ ] house well now they they
have to have jobs to bring home money
too so they can be allowed out but
like I work with like but like work
release yes work release that's the one
ankle monitors yeah exactly you pretend
it's like phones anyway but you know you
could do with the ankle monitors
monetize it put a little like break you
know little gems on it or whatever it's
like a little kid like a Pandora
bracelet oh yeah just [ __ ] bedazzle
it yeah ankle breakers Dazzle every
woman that has an ankle bracelet
is a gypsy
or toe rings toe rings are weird
yeah
yeah
oh my God this lady Let It Go
are you plastic a seed Madam not
everyone has to watch
they've been there forever
God spread in the news why would I live
here
you know why this doesn't happen in
Florida because you get shot like I mean
please understand
we have seen somebody use an alligator
as a weapon more than one time I'm not
am I lying more than once
mm-hmm and you guys are over here
[ __ ] bitching and crying and they
have to check your Facebook timeline
throwing a [ __ ] pistol
they really are God's assault lizard
they really are what's the point of them
yeah
did she just say
I'm full of barbecue like I gotta hear
that again okay hold on let's hear it
okay
oh you're full he's an idiot it's okay
I'm full of barbecue I know
I'm sorry
does anybody on okay she's drunk
obviously she's like drinking with Dad I
think both of them are
full listen
I'm all hopped up on barbecue chip and
I'm gonna beat your ass that's my point
like first off when I when I pull on
barbecue I take a nap I don't get it
have you ever eaten barbecue but ready
to fist fight somebody bro could you
imagine this [ __ ] of [ __ ]
Thanksgiving I know
[ __ ] swinging just swinging at people
and sleeping
yeah everyone's snoring while the
Cowboys lose on Thanksgiving and she's
[ __ ] and she's [ __ ] wow I just had
[ __ ]
too ma'am winging on Grandma man
barbecue should have the opposite effect
on you
oh it's [ __ ] funny dude somebody
crying in the Chacos yeah cause she's
sauced
that was right in front of bro that was
right there I'm angry that it would none
of us got I'm so good job Brian I am
angry that none of us got it took you
long enough
hey women hear me that's a [ __ ] let
me explain something to you and every
man on this call Will back me up
when you when when your man is [ __ ]
being angry or fighting with somebody
do not tell them to calm down it's only
going to make them more mad do not shush
them do not get in his way and do not
get in the line of fire from his fist
you hear me leave him alone we let you
sit there and [ __ ] about 50 minutes on
how [ __ ] Susan is a [ __ ] in the
office we're [ __ ] angry do not shush
us do not get involved leave us alone
sorry it's just the worst whenever you
see fights and we see them all the time
have to fight is a woman screaming
loudly and not doing anything but making
it worse
um
and also we're vacating the titles
bye
man that was a good one
that is a top tier crazy lady
oh yeah somebody commented but I'm full
of barbecue okay crazy lady
but I'm reading the comments to see
where people fall yeah people are people
are not on This Woman's side none of
them are okay best comment all joking
aside the husband looks like what I
imagine the average Reddit monitor looks
like moderator looks like
uh
uh and the only and then then the
comment under that the only kind of wife
or Reddit mod can find
more brutal than I am than them